you guys one night of lousy sleep can
really have a ripple effect on the rest
of your week get a better night's rest
with sleep CBD solutions from next Evo
Naturals for up to 25 off subscription
orders of 50 or more use promo code
trash Tuesday at nextevo.com that's
n-e-x-t-e-v-o.com promo code trash
Tuesday thank you to our sponsor native
their plastic free deodorant is aluminum
and paraben free it kills odor causing
bacteria and has 24-hour odor protection
to keep you feeling and smelling fresh
guys I'm All Pets okay as in my genre me
too I'm a pit princess go to
nativedeo.com Tuesday or use promo code
Tuesday at checkout and get 20 off your
first order that's
nativedeo.com Tuesday or use promo code
Tuesday at checkout for 20 off your
first order and now a word from our
sponsor betterhelp it's easy and
affordable online therapy and when you
want to be a better Problem Solver
therapy can get you there visit at
betterhelp.com trash Tuesday today to
get 10 off your first month that's
better
help.com trash Tuesday
hi slugs welcome to October
um I will be in Kansas City October 7th
through 8th at The Improv I'm gonna be
at skank Fest hell yeah I'll then be at
Irvine California just for one night on
October 20th then next month you can see
me in San Jose Michigan I'll be in
Florida and a bunch of other dates go to
annieleterman.com shows can't wait to
meet you baby hi slugs I'm back on the
road this fall I'm coming to Phoenix San
Francisco Seattle and Portland get
tickets at Esther onice.com and my new
solo podcast my pleasure is available
everywhere you listen to podcasts
since none of us have kids so we don't
know what this is like and our we didn't
burther
um our fur babies
I disagree sometimes I put Randy back in
my vagina and push him out just to be
like remember I visualized the time that
I carry donut in my womb so that like I
really feel that she's my own well okay
when we when I first got Randy Olivia
Munn gave me this like
um gave me this bag that she got on
Amazon it was 17.99 I was like Olivia I
thought it was gonna be a little more
expensive but uh she was like put your
dog in this bag she's like my dog craves
this bag like because I carried him
around when he's a puppy Randy loves
being in this bag and it feels like
you're pregnant with him he's like in
this little cloth bag and it's so cute
you got to get donut in the bag but we
have a bag we definitely have a bag but
I feel like some dogs really don't take
to that bag because I've bought
countless bags over the years and I have
a small dog named Remy who's 12. he's
really old and crusty he's toothless
um but that [ __ ] just wants to
be on all fours and piss on everything
he has no interest in being babied he
wants to imagine Esther
um but yeah I don't think all dogs
um but send me that one it's Olivia it's
honestly like the cutest dog it's like
uh if you go on Amazon it's like gray
and white and has like white it has
white stripes and then it can flip
inside out and it's got like
it looks like a picnic table I don't
know what that's called black and white
Annie let me just say one upside to um
wrapping your sweater like this armpit
look
a little dabarino yeah I just don't
always have like wetness on my knees
because I would shove my knees up to
like dry my armpits and there'd be like
deodorant on my knees better this is
sweaty sweaty girl stuff you wouldn't
understand you know but I have been
learning that you guys are way healthier
because you're releasing your toxins and
mine are all just like staying inside me
and also they're definitely coming out
somewhere else you're leaky so like in
this heat wave in La I've noticed that I
am actually sweating more and I look
prettier like my face gets glowy from
the sweat 100 any jealous of you guys
are you the one that's allowed to decide
you're getting prettier
here's like if we actually have anything
I think I'm the only one well I was
watching a thing where this girl did
like um she did I think it was Elizabeth
Taylor's makeup it was like a tick tock
and she did
um
she said that Elizabeth Taylor used to
do her own makeup back in the day
and because there was no like setting
spray or anything or anything to make it
look dewy she would do her makeup and
then she would get in the bath and let
it like steam so it's kind of like that
maybe it gives you like The Dewy sweaty
look very sexy
yeah was that so boring see I can't take
I'm not bringing the tick tock heat guys
you guys are the tick tockers I know I I
think that's interesting because I
generally think people are prettier and
stay younger longer when they live in
humid weather so it's like when I
um look at my auntie's back home that
have lived in the Philippines difficult
lives by the way compared to some of my
family members out here like including
my mom even if they're older they look
younger they just their skin has just
absorbed has been hydrated like their
entire life over here it's so dry yeah
what do they eat the most like is it
fish and
um very basic stuff like fish vegetables
um uh yeah the same rice a lot of rice
but it's it's so much of just being
hydrated I think like every single yeah
I know my hair will stay young forever
because it's oily oh my God that picture
Liz vague took of you is so good with
your hair flipped back that is so good
my oily hair is beautiful I can't
believe Hulu cut your hair off like that
too years ago that was so mean that was
the superpower you have thank you guys
my Jew hair
Jewish girls do have the best hair yeah
I think the best mix for good hair is
Jewish and Italian because I was hanging
out with this girl who's half Jewish
half Italian and she had my dream hair
was it Lady Gaga
if you hang out Lady Gaga we missed the
Lady Gaga concert do we have fomo are we
okay wait I Lady Gaga follows you yes
this is only because I was a super fan
and I think like whoever ran her social
media in 2009 just like followed her
first 1000 fans oh this is like when
Obama followed my porn star for an
awesome hero exactly it's meaningless
but that's so funny but he did it's
meaningless on paper but in my heart
deep down it's very I think we're gonna
get her guys she will be a guest well
it's basically you have a direct link to
her she's gonna read your stuff should
you decide to send it
I wonder how true that is but if it is
on social media we need to uh put our
minds together because I see her um
commenting on random tick tocker stuff
really I think she's reachable okay this
is we're manifesting this
maybe should we ask the cards yeah yes
Carlos get ready to find out what these
cards are in
all right
are we gonna get Lady Gaga
Esther you're picking okay are we all
picking
if hers is bad we'll pick again if it
doesn't give us what we want okay I got
the princess of Swords oh it looks like
Gaga a little bit it doesn't look like a
Helen Hunt it looks like David Bowie
looks like David Bowie that's one of her
biggest inspirations
okay princess swords with this card and
a career reading it's time to implement
new ideas and changes to the system yes
our efforts will be rewarded do it tweet
message her okay over time so I'll
message her every day for the rest of my
life until persistence is key but it
says it's been read
it requires understanding that we are a
part of a larger whole a member of a
team Esther she's we need a fourth what
they're saying is we need a fourth host
and it's Lady Gaga yeah the chair is
open for you miss Stephanie germanotta
we're fans of house Labs you can come
promote that here no we really are I
have all the lip glosses the lip glass
what do you call it okay
wait so did you guys see this article it
was in Vogue about
clingy girls having it right all along
so it says when it comes to
relationships have clingy girls had it
right all along so basically what what
do you mean by clingy like stage five
like so like the girls who are playing
games and which by the way I'm guilty of
all levels of this like I've played
games I've been a Clinger I've done it
all but like if you just come right out
and are like saying what you want and
not trying to be small or be pick me or
pretend playing it cool
then you'll actually get what you want
in life it's yes because that's just
setting boundaries for yourself but also
it's like it's like let the person like
say no and move on right the thing is
you get like attached to the idea of
wanting it to be that person so then
you're like I'll play these games and
I'll manipulate them but if they don't
like who you are they got to go so
you're just wasting time but you have to
like get you have to like go through it
a million times yeah I feel like maybe
this is a little bit like too broad to
say okay all clingy girls have been
doing it right because I've seen clingy
and I've that [ __ ] can get like scary
this article I'm not looking right at
you either what are you saying Carlos
just said this article says that true
clinginess like what's mistaken for
being cleaning is actually just anxiety
so if you're just like calling a guy
that's not even clingy that the guy
probably wants right I'm I I think I
definitely have been at fault with
playing the cool girl for so long that I
abandoned my own boundaries and
um because it's like even when I was
younger right it was like you got you
were very much rewarded for being one of
the guys it was such a prize when a dude
all of of your boyfriend's friends were
like yeah and no girls except like yeah
no girls except kalila she's cool and
it's like actually I don't want to be
one of the guys I'd be I want to be one
of the girls like I it was um because I
found myself like never truly being
comfortable and always trying really
hard to drink more to know they were
like open with me about their secrets
and infidelities and I'm like I don't
want to be the she was always putting
Gold Bond powder on her balls it was she
was doing everything
and after a while I was like I want to
be uh you know little fragile girl like
I don't want to be one of the guys like
I wanna I don't fought you for that at
all because even me who I feel like I
could literally be the face of
clinginess if it were a brand like that
is just who I am look at those little
hands look at those little clingies even
me like I have totally tried to play the
game I've totally like read all those
like dating books and tried to
pretend that I'm not obsessively dude
when I first started dating a guy I
literally would have to be like keep it
in your head keep it in your head
because when we're laying in bed
together I literally want to say I love
you I love you and I'm just like say it
in your head stay in your head don't say
it out loud which like that's probably a
good boundary to have so like there is a
balance but
like just I think that it's not our
fault that we've been trained to be like
gotta play a pool like don't let them
don't come on too strong they have been
trained for movies they're saying that
in all these movies from the 2000s and
90s of being the clingy girl was not
cool and that gen Z there's a
generational shift with it right now and
it's turning into lover girls which is
I'm a lover girl I think that now I'm at
a different stage in my life where
um I really just want to present as me
up front before
um even like when I met Bobby it was
always like you're gonna drive to me
you're gonna do this because I was just
still playing the game of like I need he
needs to respect me he needs to but it's
like no I'm a lover girl I'm sweet I say
I love you maybe a little bit too soon
because I feel my feelings very deeply
and I get attached to people very
quickly and [ __ ] it if that's who I am
that's who I am am I a lover girl too
you're a lover girl
are you yeah
listen I anxious attachment style like
that's a part of who I am trying so hard
not to be it's like yeah I can't tell
you many times I would just like just
try so hard to Broad down and I was just
coughing down my emotions like I was
just like shoving them down just like no
I don't like you sure go out with her I
don't care I'm just like crying but I
think I was really addicted to like the
pining feeling because I think I didn't
have to actually face my true feelings I
didn't have to be vulnerable if I was
like the one that wanted them secretly I
was always like the Taylor Swift song
You Know
I was always on the bleachers
to me like I'm supposed to be the one
you know and then in my head I had some
like romantic idea that we'd all like
end up together at some point not all of
us I don't know why I made it sound like
that but when Harem so you're saying
when you did that it was almost like a
form of protection yeah because you
didn't have to put yourself yeah if I
really like what if I was like no I'm
actually really into you and they're
like oh me too then I'd be like what wow
I don't have to do that but isn't that
all we've ever done is to just do
everything we can to like self-preserve
it's like we didn't we weren't guided we
weren't told you know like there was
just no guidance in terms of like
relationships or sex so yeah you just
you know make all the mistakes you can
and be called you know either you bro
down or be called a crazy [ __ ] you had
two options right and my mom is like she
is like a bro down like she was like the
she was on the boys the men's
racquetball team and stuff like is that
legal yeah yes it is my mom was uh a
Pioneer listen to you guys I broke down
so hard for a dude that I would watch
I'd be I accidentally became a huge fan
of both the WWE and UFC like to this day
I watch I don't miss a fight card at
like last Saturday I'm alone in my room
and on my iPad watching UFC right by
myself because I accidentally brought
down too hard when I was 18. for a boy I
really like I'm a part of your identity
and then now he's like oh wow yeah it
just became a part of me now when you
say bro down you're saying that is an
example of you being a clingy girl right
like yes yeah okay yeah same and then he
would say things like yeah dude my
girl's so cool she watches fights with
me and in the beginning I hated it I'm
like I don't really care about you know
Tank Abbott but over time I started to
really care about Tank Abbott and then I
would go on to forums I'm like where is
Tank Abbott now you need to like go like
share this story with all the young
women be like you might accidentally
start liking Sports you need to be
careful this is a dangerous game and
then when I was 26 I put in a submission
I think I tried to reach out to someone
because I wanted to be Joe Rogan's
sidekick I was there's a guy named Mike
Goldberg who did a wonderful job being a
um he wasn't a color commentator but he
was on the side of the Octagon basically
and for the longest time I was like I'm
gonna I would Manifest this in my head
I'm gonna to be that girl ringside I am
going to do I'm going to do this with
Joe Rogan one day that's how hard I
broke down
the way he's looking at him imagine
that's you gazing into
her mouth and I knew nothing about
fighting I don't fight never don't have
a background in martial arts like I just
thought in my head because I had [ __ ]
wanted to broke down so hard for this
dude was it your beautiful Asian eyes
you know I had face Annie for noticing
your little cross-eyed but I have had a
policy and I wonder like where it lands
if it's right or wrong or whatever but
like basically in middle school I was
dating this guy and I was like really
stewing I was like mad over something I
don't remember what but I remember
telling my sister like I'm so mad about
this like I just want him he needs to
call me and she was like
why don't you just call him she's like
you're sitting here upset and angry and
like you're just punishing yourself just
call him and see what the deal is and I
was like oh you're right like and so
that really put me on the path of being
someone that like speaks up and like
reaches out which I still can't tell if
that's the right path or not maybe this
article about being clingy is like
saying it is but then I've also sent
really crazy texts to date like in the
first month of our relationship but I
don't like like
the first month of our relationship he
went away for a weekend to a wedding and
he didn't call me after a day and I
texted him my famous words I guess this
is the weekend we drift apart
and then five minutes later he called me
and said what is going on
and you're like obviously nothing that's
why I'm obsessed with you
I loved that guy you called is probably
like watching this podcast going like so
it's her sister's fault
she's driving by my house every day
I do appreciate that I think that
um the kind of man that would appreciate
that kind of assertiveness and saying
like because
the way I feel when I like someone or at
least now my game plan is that if I like
him I'm gonna say I like him I'm not
going to try to you know play koi and if
he is taken aback or uncomfortable with
me just being like a little bit more
assertive then great we don't have to
yeah that's not fine it's not for me
it's not compatible I don't want to have
to it's exhausting to have to like
figure out the chess game we're also
like older so it's like if you wait he's
gonna get married
is gonna be married next month you know
what I mean it's like you have not that
if they're already dating someone or
whatever but you know what I mean it's
like people find their people so it's
like there's not like you don't have the
time you had like when you're in high
school or college to kind of play it
cool it's like and I feel like I have to
talk yeah and then at this age you have
more of the tools now so things can move
a little bit um faster and if a guy's my
age are not ready for a relationship
it's like
go handle your demons all right guys I'm
getting married
by that I mean I'm getting married um
but yeah
um chess game no more I think it takes
up too much of my brain cells don't have
time for it I agree like let's just
decide like there's no time we have
fulfilled lives outside of like just get
to the answer you don't have to play
like a whole [ __ ] dance to get to
like
like the answer is the answer yeah even
the answer I think that I used to do
this though and with my anxious anxious
attachment I would go on like one date
with a guy and then I'd want to know
where he stood and it's like I didn't
even like know where I stood yet like I
needed to know what they thought of me
before I could decide what I thought of
them and that's like so [ __ ]
unhealthy and then they don't know like
if I don't know they don't know either
it's like I didn't give it time to like
kind of like unfold I just was like do
you like me or not like what's happening
you know what's crazy is how many like
marriages and like babies get made in
that stage still just like what do they
think what do I yeah you know like not
knowing not being clear
I have to say that if I don't get a good
night's sleep I actually can't function
the whole day like my day's room you can
learn all the tools from therapy from
Tick Tock from all the things in the
world but if you're tired it's gone and
if you're struggling to get a good
night's rest or you just want to wake up
more refreshed you should check check
out the Sleep CBD solutions from next
Evo Naturals next Evo's Precision
formulations are backed by more
scientific studies than any other CBD
brand so if you're someone who's been
looking to get a more restful night's
sleep with a natural approach next Evo
CBD products are definitely the way to
go honestly it's been great for me
because after I get off stage like my
sets are so late I'm so hyper the
adrenaline's like running through my
veins I'm taking pictures with all you
slugs I'm having a great time and then
all of a sudden it's like you know one
two in the morning and I have to get up
early so it has just been amazing to
just help me
wind down wind down you guys wind down
and get a better night's rest with sleep
CBD solutions from next Evo Naturals for
up to 25 off subscription orders of 50
or more use promo code trash Tuesday at
next evo.com that's
n-e-x-t-e-v-o.com promo code trash
Tuesday you guys I cannot say enough
great things about Native yes I use not
just their deodorants I use their
shampoos I use everything native I'm a
native girl through and through you've
heard me talk about it how much I love
them
um they are really really I'm somebody
who just like Annie pits out I always
always I'm never not sweating from my
armpits but guess what I Never Smell
with Native choose from 10 cents
including their classic coconut and
vanilla and they have sensitive formulas
that are formulated without baking soda
and they even have an unscented and
sadly I am an unscented girl and not a
lot of Brands make unscented like I
literally have to seek that out and so
glad native does it and they do it right
I personally love their eucalyptus and
mint I believe and I think there's
another one it's the lavender the
lavender and Rose oh it smells so good
at the cities I'm OG coconut vanilla I
want to be a pina colada I want to be an
ice cream I like smelling like ice cream
okay that's my move also native is now
plastic free in their packaging which is
kind of unheard of for deodorant it's so
awesome it makes me feel so much better
about using it every day are you guys
ready to try plastic free deodorant go
to nativedeo.com Tuesday or use promo
code Tuesday at checkout and get 20 off
your first order that's
nativedeo.com Tuesday or use promo code
Tuesday at checkout for 20 off your
first order definitely worth checking
out plastic free deodorant it's just a
nice way that they've made my life a
little easier a little less plastic
not knowing in that uncertainty really
does drive like sexual energy and I get
that that's why people who employ the
tactic of roller coaster manipulation
which is something I just learned yeah
which is like what's that
um someone who it's it's uh a lot of
times it's what maybe narcissists do a
little bit where the Peaks and the Peaks
are really peaky but the valleys are
very low so it's like you're when you're
in a valley when the good times are
really good and then they take you back
down all the way here but you're already
anticipating how good this is this is
gonna feel so it's like it's a way to
manipulate someone to always sort of
like hang in there you could look it up
but were they like emotional
rollercoaster manipulation wait look at
this look how many tampons are coming on
my purse so many tampons Annie you said
there was a thing called an ultra I got
an ultra tampon have you heard of the
disaster I'm gonna sacrifice one okay
look how big this is this is bigger than
Esther's entire body
whoa I'm impressed
Let's Wet it let's see how big it gets
how many I'm gonna dip it in my
how many hours does this um last you
what how many hours on your strongest
day does this last you three
oh boy this is not because I have a big
[ __ ] okay it's a heavy flow I don't
want to be here in no big [ __ ] comments
NFL mouth guard
Carlos will you come suck this try
come on if kale holds it it's just water
come on Carlos pick it up we can't move
Carlos are you in trouble with the
internet today yeah actually oh wait do
you want to come back do you want to get
this is your Redemption moment I don't
know what happened but this is the way
out
all right
kalila you have to hold it you guys have
tension it's like a mistletoe it's just
water you look dehydrated it's our
mistletoe
should give you a sponge bath with it I
said it's our mistletoe she's gonna get
her mistletoe take the hint I have to do
bad friends after this kiss her
wait wait not the tampon
oh it's a missile camel toe okay sure
all right
I went tight-lipped with it you're so
gentle and sweet yeah I was trying to be
chill
yeah I'm not gonna lie wait what do you
mean did he try to make out with I think
so because I did this it was gentle it
wasn't like aggressive this is very
aggressive
your reaction look at the drip that's
going down his head
here you go Carlos again
having to suck it yeah okay you take
that over there is there trash can big
enough for it well Carlos very soft
honestly my only takeaway right now is I
really want to borrow your jeans
they look so good
um Carlos how did that feel kissing
kalila those juicy lips well it goes
well with how with how Andrew kind of
spilled what's going on today yeah well
Andrew was talking about his time on
trash Tuesday at bad friends oh no now
everyone wants me fired
well we want you fired too if that'll
help
you're here for
[Laughter]
some okay here we go yeah
was there a little sexual tension in the
room there was and you know who was
between who Delilah and Carlos I have to
say this too right I think that you're
the reason why we're not together
and no sexual term
I see you in the videos
I know but I've seen you on stage you
don't ham it up you are not trying to do
a good job badly Carlos
that's where we know you're lying
Carlos took it from the Esther the
Esther uh Camp which is like trying's
grows ew that's so funny there's a thing
now called Silent quitting that I just
learned about yeah yeah I was looking
about that quiet quitting I don't quite
you just don't do like the extra work
like you don't yeah quiet quitting is
called You're about to get fired like
that anymore not anymore especially not
in the field of nursing because they are
so understaffed everywhere go ahead and
try and fire a nurse right now she'll go
get hired somewhere else so it's like
it's basically a nurses perfect
opportunity to set her boundaries make
sure that she's not getting freaking
eight patients to one nurse good that
she's getting the break that she's
there's so many dead Seasons
the patients are it's not that quiet
because all he hears
[Music]
wow thanks nurses but it's actually that
there's like there's a manipulation into
trying to get them to do overtime to
just go beyond what their like human be
humanly capable of doing it's such a
cost to their mental health it's a
[ __ ] difficult job and I have to say
as someone who identifies as a patient I
want my nurses to have peace I want them
to just focus on only a couple then
don't go to them then you are not the
one for them Esther
definitely I respect nurses setting
their boundaries but not when I'm the
patient but for if Carlos plans on quiet
quitting that won't go on this one
Carlos quiet hired what are we talking
about here
Carlos gets so mad when we ask him to do
something except he did give me my
coffee thank you so much yeah are you
drinking a Modelo kind of it's such a oh
my God Carlos
wait Carlos should be the face of quiet
quitting
nobody said there's no drinking and
podcasting this is not a normal job the
Modelo looks like loud quitting though
it's as loud as you can get did I ever
tell you guys about when I got uh fired
from working on Impractical Jokers did I
tell you that story no okay so
it's so good it's actually you're gonna
love it okay so I was writing on the
show for I was only supposed to do three
weeks okay I made it like a week and a
half it's like how do you get fired from
a job that has like an end date
that's out soon it was like it was
insane so okay so I get hired I didn't
really want to do it I like the show and
everything but I just don't like doing
writing jobs because I like to use my
Creative Energy for myself but the the
um Casey Jost was in a Colin Joe's
brother who's so funny was in The
Writer's room this guy Andrew Law like
it we were having [ __ ] fun and um the
show runner this was was like I didn't
even know what a showrunner was but the
show Runner comes in one day okay and
all the guys that they were having this
this like meeting and the punishment so
how Impractical Jokers work is like they
prank each other and then if you don't
do the prank you have to like get a
punishment so the punishment was going
to be that we were brainstorming was
different tattoos that they would have
to get and the showrunner had worked on
jackass so he was like you guys should
get a tattoo on your balls I have a
friend that got a tattoo on his balls
and he got so much [ __ ] from it and I
just went
I don't know and everybody went like
what and I went no I'm just over here
working no big deal and they go no Annie
what were you saying and I go I just
don't think anyone's ever been like
whether there's a tattoo or not any
girls ever like hold that dick back let
me get those balls like I came to [ __ ]
you because of your balls and so the
like all the guys start laughing and
then the shower and goes get back to
work
and I was like oh I guess I'm in trouble
who cares
um so then two days later two days later
I get called out into the um by the
showrunner into the like other Roman he
goes I know you're on coke
and I went what I had been sober for
four years we had had powdered donuts
earlier and I was I'm a pig you know so
like they were just like pow like
powdered sugar all over my shirt which
is like if I was on coke like it
wouldn't have dropped any it was like
all over me and he's like I know you're
on cook I thought I was being pranked
because it's a prank show so I was like
lol like what and he's like you're on
coke I know you're on coke and I was
like I'm not on [ __ ] code I go oh I
know we ate powdered donuts and I talk a
lot like I don't know what to say
and I went into the trash can like
pulled the donuts out I'm like I'm
digging in the trash man
but the reason that reminded me of it
because it's like when was there an
agreement that you're not doing coke in
a writer's room by the way
even affect the writer's room it would
actually be a very sign of respect to
the show I'm just trying to get more
done real fast okay maybe all the pranks
are about middle school but who cares
but anyway so
um so then I ended up they he found some
like he was like uh we don't really like
your writing and they fired me like two
days later it's not about that it's
about the coke
it's because you're accusing of code
because I quit I was like I'm not coming
back to the show because you just
accused me of doing coke that's insane I
was like are you pranking me he's like I
don't know you well enough to prank him
like this is the craziest thing in the
world I am not on cocaine so then the
guy is like q and Sal were like texting
me like please stay don't quit like and
so I came back in and then two days
later they were like the guys don't like
your writing and I go these guys and I
scrolled through and showed them other
things and they're like oh uh
and then some kid from the production
was like I've always been a fan of yours
I was working on the production I just
want to let you know this was like years
later he's like that guy ended up
getting fired after that season because
of what he did too it was so [ __ ] up
like we all knew it oh my God but is
that so funny well it's like but I talk
so much to someone there's nothing about
this in the wga code of working roles I
think yeah as your lawyer I think we
have no but you know who my lawyer was
back then oh God and my lawyer was like
they were so gaslighter they're like it
was probably your writing like it wasn't
my writing
I think it wasn't my writing oh my God
the the fact that like all these people
in entertainment have had this lawyer
who literally is like we hired but is
working against us I never hired him he
just started telling people who's my
lawyer I was like
have you ever been fired Esther
um
I've been I've I think I have actually
quietly quit slash gotten fired because
when I worked at press Juicery
uh in in West Hollywood they just
stopped putting me on the schedule and I
guess would you refuse to press you're
like
I why there was a lot of like
requirements to stand when the chair was
right there and I was just like I I for
you to sit at your height though it's
like it looks like no one's there it was
actually a real issue I had that happen
at my um
my um Pizza job when I was 15 they just
like stopped calling me to come into
work and I never asked why
have you I can't think of like a
specific sit down and getting fired but
I worked at a place for one day and um
I'm pretty sure it was we looked at each
other in the eyes and you're like well
we didn't even no one got fired and no
one fired anyway I mean no one no one
quit and no one fired anyone we both
looked at each other at the end of the
day and both knew no one was coming back
but then I still went back were you
wearing eye makeup my little Asian eyes
were in full display that day I have
been fired
um but then do you think that it was
right of me to go back and get my 68
check yeah okay okay that's your money
if you didn't go get it they'd have to
send it to you like that's yours it was
at a shoe store too and it I just it
just wasn't for me I was just like
putting side you just have to have a
foot fetish that has to be the only
reason you're doing that job and it was
like a shoe store for like older Italian
men you could have had a husband
you could have had a weld shoot husband
I got epically fired epically fired I
was working at this hotel called Hotel
Saint Francis in in Santa Fe New Mexico
and I had worked at so many of the
restaurants there this was like I was a
cocktail waitress and I liked the job I
had a couple different jobs in town but
I was like making bank you know and 90
days I didn't know I was on like a
90-day trial or whatever so they sat me
down like you know we decided to not
hire you after 90 days and I was like
making bank I like couldn't I was like
friends with everyone except there was
one bartender that didn't like me
and um so I guess she just was like I
don't like working with her they fired
me and I go well I was like so shocked
because I was there like dressed ready
to work so I was like oh all right so I
left and I went to another bar and I was
like I just got fired and everyone's
like buying me shots and stuff and I was
like they're like [ __ ] those people so
we all went back like wasted I brought
like a wasted like bar of people back to
hotel St Francis like a fancy nice hotel
and
um and we all like all the girls started
making out in front of all the security
cameras and like showing her tits my
friend Julian was bartending he's like
this is the best time of my life and
then
um they were just like laughing and then
the security guards were like Annie I
mean we have to tell you to stop but
this is awesome
but because I knew everyone it was just
so funny but we just every we just
caused like a scene tits were out
tongues everyone was just hammered
[ __ ] going 69 and I was like I dare
you to fire me they're like yes Annie
this is the behavior we fired
I got I actually have a very like almost
too soon to share a story but I got me
and my friends kicked out of a nice
hotel in Italy a couple weeks ago and it
was I know I haven't even told you
Carlos like it was you are watching the
news too loud they're bumming everyone
out wait that's you're just following
after Bobby's footsteps yet again oh God
he's been banned from a couple hotels in
Hawaii Carlos is gonna steal Dave from
you now there was beautiful
piano music being played and I was drawn
to it we were sitting in this Lounge in
this beautiful bar and the Amalfi Coast
and in a really nice hotel and
um The Pianist to like taking a break
and then my friend's sister went and sat
down and she started playing My Heart
Will Go On It was so beautiful I
couldn't help but like get up and start
doing some
balletic movement and I thought it was
going great like I thought I was killing
and I was just starting to really feel
myself and all of a sudden this Italian
man in a suit marches over and he was so
mean he goes too much
ouch
it's like not that mean Esther's always
like no Annie um but in a foreign
country a man is also she's fully
feeling herself like you're so
vulnerable she's the freaking Prima
ballerina at this point I'll just never
forget these this finger move are you
like this or something when he did it
like your leg up it was like way worse
it was like so emotional was there a
crowd gathering for you just like the
group that I was with and then I had to
like look at all my friends who are
cooler than me and be like I guess we
have to leave now it was so shameful no
Esther you're wrong really because this
is what's good about you is these
moments where we're not sure how it's
gonna go
that's what's funny about you you like
you can you make the room to a point
where you're like is this
bad or good what's happening right when
we used to like attack people and ask
them what they ate for breakfast right
you don't know if they're like are they
gonna be mad at us or not it's like
sometimes it works it's pesty it's like
we're being pests and they're not sure
for good pests or bad pass but like
that's what was funny about when you
were dancing when Natasha was singing oh
yeah because it was like we couldn't
tell if Natasha liked it or not yeah
and you just kept going and you were
like doing it out of like a love for
what she was doing and it was but it was
like it was the tension in the moment
and then it ended up being the perfect
thing okay thank you I think maybe the
results are never going to be medium
it's either yeah kicked out or you have
Natasha Bedingfield in love with you
right so it's like one of the two so
she's maybe right it's like it's always
going to be an extreme outcome so it's
worth taking right I will say I was like
it was the first Memorial I'm like oh
we're not in Kansas anymore like this is
a foreign country like they will ask me
to leave like I'm breaking cultural
rules I just felt really scared like
Spirit moved you yeah yeah I mean My
Heart Will Go On in an Italian like were
they mad at your friend for playing the
piano
I don't know like maybe it wasn't but I
did try to blame her I was like she was
playing My Heart Will Go On like I
couldn't control my body was she good
she was really good yeah
guy just had to stick up his butt maybe
yeah I think that's just that
I think maybe they just don't had to be
there yeah yeah they don't want that
they don't want that they're like who is
this young girl who's this tiny baby
girl
you guys ever find it tough to train
your brain to stay in problem solving
mode yeah I work in it all the time
because of the help I get from Better
Health I mean it's like it's you forget
you could just be mindfully going
through life just why am I so miserable
and what I sometimes I tend to do is I
stay fixated on the problem rather than
looking for Solutions I just stay there
just like stewing over something instead
of finding a way out of it oh totally
that is probably my number one issue is
focusing on a problem and not focusing
on actually solving that problem like
that is everyone I know I think suffers
from that and it really takes time with
a therapist to work that through because
we just get in these Loops in our head
and we go round and round and the same
thing over and over and you need someone
else's perspective to kind of help shift
you away from that yeah I'm dizzy guys
I'm done can we all just be done with it
let's just stop the spinning let's just
get the help let's just get better let's
not
wallow you know just get the help you
need and better help makes it so easy
better help is customize online therapy
it's super affordable you can get
matched to therapist in under 48 hours
they have a really great Journal feature
and if let's suppose the first therapist
is not a match they make it very easy to
find another therapist you don't have to
worry about feeling like you're
rejecting anyone it's this is how it
works my life really did not improve
until I started seeing a therapist like
I just can't say enough good things
about therapy I've worked through so
many issues with my therapist and I
think if you're someone especially who's
thought about therapy but has you know
been a little too shy or you know just
had things get in your way better help
is definitely the place to start and
when you want to be a better Problem
Solver therapy can get you there visit
betterhelp.com trash Tuesday today to
get 10 off your first month that's
better help.com trash Tuesday
okay so there's this Theory
um
um swirling around on Tick Tock that the
reason that Nick Cannon um is having
multiple babies at lightning speed is
because he was diagnosed with um lupus
nephritis which is a very Insidious kind
of Lupus that attacks the kidneys and
that he's really just creating a kidney
farm for himself should the time come
that he needs a kidney transplant what
are you I like it I instantly forgive
him for everything I love that she's
like a fellow victim
why do you think Esther hangs out with
us she's harvesting us yes yes thank you
for knowing and being okay with it
um you can have one of you can have my
spleen
but it's like
um and the other theory is like you know
he has twins with Mariah right yeah
there's no way in hell she'd allow for
one of her kids to give up a kidney to
their father so he's just um gonna
Harvest from one of his other 55
Offspring and maybe he thinks the more
he diversifies the mothers then the
better chances that the kidneys will
work out different matches right because
I think that there's a 50 chance that
the child will inherit the genetics or
the or lupus so in order to up his
chances of kidney prospects he would
like if it's a 50 chance having two more
kids would mean you can only really get
one of two wait if you have 20 then you
have 10 options no now this is [ __ ] up
because it's I do think if you're gonna
be one of these super producers where
you make all these babies it's like you
need if you have genetic issues like
that's not fair to all these kids you're
making because did you guys see that
documentary on Netflix about the doctor
oh my God
the Doctor Who was secretly did you
watch I didn't watch a doctor but I read
about it when it happened I was getting
my eggs at that moment so I was like I
don't think it's time
it is wild there are so many people that
he inseminated and he had like some
health problems and so all these kids
are like Mad like I mean I guess it's
such a weird concept to like be mad at
the person like you wouldn't exist if it
wasn't for him I don't I can't even
imagine getting into their heads and how
to deal with that trauma but
it is fun now I hate it again and again
that's the moral of the story I have
another question for you guys speaking
of lupus nephritis so I think that it's
like pretty well documented it's Selena
Gomez has something like similar where
she's had to get a kidney transplant
from her friend is it Risa or Isa right
it was like her best friend who gave up
a kidney yeah and gave it to Selena but
apparently there was like a rift of the
Friendship afterwards because Selena was
you know drinking and kind of like
living her life after the person had
already given her kidney with a new
kidney what are your thoughts on let's
say for instance you you give a piece of
your liver to somebody and then because
they are um or else they they wouldn't
live to see the next two years and then
you see him start like partying
but now you're like it really depends on
how much they paid me are you paying for
my silence but I guess I I don't know I
think if I once I give you a piece of me
it's yours you do it right whatever you
want I wouldn't police you no no I know
you sir don't worry if you have been
given my one of my organs like we have
strict protocol to follow like oh my God
that's why Esther wants to give you an
order yes yes it's like it's like having
a iPhone tracker
by having such a location well do you
think you have a say in how that person
lives because you're one kidney less yes
I think that we have to come to an
agreement beforehand a prenup or
whatever and a pre-cut
and there's going to be some rules you
know like I think this is my one chance
at really like making someone do what I
say Esther's the only person that's like
if you're gonna take my organ you're
taking my full body and she makes you so
hurt
your Siamese yeah I definitely think
there would be rules you know
curfew for sure
what time 9 p.m sending in pictures of
the outfits each day is this outfit okay
lights out at 11 like this is no more
showers only baths maybe I need the
reverse of Nick Cannon and I just want
to have a large group of people that I
give some kind of organ to and then they
have to follow all my rules and play
games with me
maybe I should have kids is that where
this is headed
see look at this wow
what a sweet friendship moment but I
guess I would be a little I I wouldn't
know I would annoy me if someone was
like going hard on the drink
I mean I obviously don't know if that's
true or if that's what happened but like
you know um that's alleged right but
I think you would annoy me I think your
initial reaction is the truest most
right one which is like when you give
someone something it's theirs yeah it's
over for you like it's theirs and you
there's just you have no control over I
am and like I think if you're going to
be a person who gives unfortunately you
have to come to terms with math yeah
same like when you lend people money
you're giving them money you can't
expect money back that's the one thing
my dad taught me at a very young age and
about your beautiful Asian eyes
um but basically that
um if you are in a position to lend
like and that person is in the position
to even ask you like don't even you're
never gonna see it back like it's going
to destroy a friendship if you think
there's going to be a three-week
turnaround of getting your money back
and I don't know I don't give unless I
know I'm okay with never seeing it again
I have to say that I
have given real thought inside my brain
that I would like to do a fecal matter
transplant from a hot girl but why a hot
girl what if her gut biome is no good
well assuming that the like I that's
what I want like a hot girl who has like
the perfect health the perfect eating
like I would love that girl wants
nothing to do know she was not to be
near I could get near her [ __ ] okay
that's what this is I would literally
get her [ __ ] and have it like in one of
donuts bags they put it in those little
poop pills so you're basically you want
to repopulate your gut with a hot girl's
gut
um biome yeah how does this stuff work
the it does so the fecal transplants
work when you they use they used to use
it for this thing or they still do for
the thing called C diff which is like a
hospital acquired
um issue where um it is like an
overgrowth of bacteria in your gut that
causes like intractable diarrhea and
really like it it smells so specific
like when you walk into a room with
someone with C diff you don't miss it
you're like that c-diff I smelled a GI
bleed once and I'll never forget this
that's a funny that's a that's a strange
smell I'll never forget it wait what do
you mean I went I was I had to go to the
emergency room and I someone I went what
the hell is that smell like it's a GI
bleed to get used to it in here what is
that what does it smell like it's a
doo-dooy smell it's a probably the smell
of like
um heme too like there's that kind of
like Rusty rust smell if there's blood
there what does that mean a GI bleed it
just means you have a bleed somewhere in
your gastrointestinal tract it's poopy
and bloody smelling so depending on
where like what what your where you're
bleeding your poop looks a certain way
so if it's higher black poops how we
become yeah if it's higher up then I
mean then it's probably going to be
black wait is that what you guys call me
black poop
way worse
um but yeah they used to for C diff they
would I think they still use it
um they use the who's kakas do they get
um probably I don't know is that can you
get like paid like the way you can go on
first perm donor oh Republicans do it
should we try and donate our um poop I
don't think mine's that great I don't
think mine is either but I have a couple
friends where I'm like I think I would
take their what about what about I can't
wait for the end of that friendship
you're the donor recorder okay here are
the donor requirements Esther
um so no antibiotic exposure in the past
six months okay my mouth I'm out because
I had an ear infection it's not
immunocompromised
um it's not at risk for infectious
disease what does it even mean does not
live with any chronic gastrointestinal
I'm out gastrointestinal disorders I
have Colitis
um will need to be screened for HEPA
yeah obviously all the diseases and
stuff and that's a thing right there
they have to be screened for seed um C
difficile and that's the C diff I was
telling you guys about see I like the
the nickname C diff yeah I think I'm not
accepting any new people into my life
unless they fit this requirement
I'm only accepting people who [ __ ] can I
just say then you're [ __ ] you're
[ __ ] because I don't know a hot girl
that doesn't have gi problems all Kim
Kardashian Kanye just said she's always
on the toilet like with chronic diarrhea
kalila that was not true right Carlos
yeah I heard it was not it was a hoax
okay how how is it I think like a fan
made it oh it was a fan posted okay but
hot girls
um are known to always have
stomach aches what do you guys think
about Ray J coming out on Kris Jenner
about having three options of sex tapes
and then he brought the he pulled out
the contract and stuff let the man speak
his truth yeah I think it's a weird I I
think it's like
we all kind of know the truth and it is
gets a it gets frustrating when people
keep trying to hide stuff yeah because
it's like we're not you're just treating
us like we're stupid a little bit but at
the same time like if that's the way you
guys live your lives isn't the price of
certain type of Fame though like hey you
gotta keep the secrets
and maybe he's like he's breaking that
like
wait I agreement to that type of Fame
that he was getting do you know what I
mean well somebody on Tick Tock I don't
know who could have been Bethenny
Frankel on one of her can't I love her
but she basically said
um here is a man who has to explain to
his children
um why he's being called
um what do you call it like a man who
took it who was exploitative of a woman
because that's the narrative that's
right the you know the Kardashians even
have run with right like this was a
leaked tape and it was leaked by Ray J
and so now he has children he has to
explain that to you because and if he
doesn't feel like he was exploitative
and it was something that they both
agreed on then yeah he should be able to
speak his truth if that is in fact what
happened I agree one thing I'll say that
I feel like I've learned is
you also truly never know what's going
on and like I do I I don't know but just
because there's a contract it doesn't
necessarily mean that like it wasn't
something that was unavoidable like who
knows maybe like this the tape was going
to be leaked and they were like we might
as well do put our best foot forward and
reshoot it like I don't know
but
I just almost like
are you upset that someone's like saying
something bad about Kim well I was
saying that but also that somebody's
like showing a contractor like contracts
are kind of my thing yeah I'm jealous
on tracks before but no it is scary to
think like because on the other end it's
like if like if I'm having someone work
for me or whatever like they do need to
sign an NDA
but it's like are they gonna then post
the NDA and go look I had to sign this
NDA type thing right and they could do
that and then not that you're gonna
catch me doing anything I haven't
already said I done banana break I'll
try banana
by the way someone could literally just
post an NDA from you and think about
what people could make up in their heads
from just that a forced fecal transplant
I shoved my poopy into their butthole
like I my my thing lately is just you
have no idea what people are going
through what they have gone through like
look at Shia LaBeouf he was Enemy of the
State like Enemy Number One for years
and then he came forward with like that
really I thought eloquent email to
Olivia Wilde saying how he's working on
himself similar like he has to explain
to his children things like and he's
putting in the work and it makes me go
back and think like God knows what child
star Shia LaBeouf turned massive movie
star like who knows what kind of trauma
that guy has been put through what he's
dealt with like it certainly doesn't
excuse his abuses but that's why I asked
you guys last time it's like what is the
Redemption Arc for somebody like this
how much of forgiveness do we offer
someone who just years ago FKA Twiggs
said you know wanted to kill her
basically you know what I mean so it's
like here's a guy who was accused of not
only sexual assault of [ __ ] being
like slightly homicidal to towards this
other woman like how much grace do we
offer when they're on the path under
they're on the correct path to getting
better also we don't know him so how are
we forgiving someone what are you
talking about I swim with them all the
time I do oh you know I don't right he's
always on the opposite lane this is one
school I swim at no well thank you for
for pointing that out because because
you're right I don't know him and I
don't know what I actually am not
educated on like what his accusations
are and his abuse and stuff but I am
more looking at it from a place of
honestly Jeanette McCurdy's book coming
out and just shining a light on how
traumatic her upbringing was and seeing
like we have no idea what these people
went through with their child stars or
anyone who like was in the Limelight
like we just don't know and I I
personally feel like I've want to give
Grace to that I do too I I and that's
exactly why I'm saying this it's like
I'm always caught between uh do we even
the abusers in my life
I'm always like
you know for a long time I was like they
should never work again they should do
this that doctor should never do this
but like if I'm granting myself
um the grace to change and evolve as a
human to you know to be kinder to be a
better person like shouldn't I offer
extend that same yeah but the doctor who
fingered you shouldn't be fingering they
can't really like you know it's like
it's hard because like with my teacher I
remember when when
um when I first like told like one to
the cops and everything after my teacher
molested me I got all these calls from
his wife
that were like well at first I was like
you [ __ ] [ __ ] blah blah blah and
then like the next day he had he went to
jail for one night and she called and
she was like you know we realized since
he went to jail like he was molested too
and I kind of was like I don't give a
[ __ ] it doesn't exist I go I don't give
a [ __ ] [ __ ] he just jerked off on me
right so like I want to be clear on that
like at no point is are you or anything
that's like a cute you know but everyone
everyone has like whatever their life is
you know they have whatever they were
given whatever they happened to them
let's paint that scenario let's suppose
some like a comedian that you know say
for instance has been accused of um sex
realism I can't imagine it
it's too hard it's too much of a stretch
like just being like chronically a [ __ ]
shitty guy to young women yeah being a
sex addict being a cheater
um just bad abusive sexual practices
emotionally abusive all of the above
um but then you see that not only has he
gone to essay meetings
um or SLA meetings
um no he is in therapy he's doing all of
the work you can possibly think of to
try and see the error of his ways but
then you hear rumors that it's still
going on he's still doing it
oh there's okay but let's suppose that's
not the truth of it and let's say like
you see him just really like coming out
of it with Clarity and being like Oh
like I [ __ ] up it's just a
hypothetical
like where do we stand on that where do
we or we still trepidatious are we like
I don't trust this person are we like
okay I thank you for doing the work you
have a long way to go like where do we
stand on that yeah
um I think there should be a path to
Redemption of course like if people want
to but it's also like this is all like
public opinion so it's like we're not
really supposed to be in front of all
these people having all these people
decide who we are and what we are really
what it is is like it's this is a
[ __ ] individual's game this is a solo
game okay we have our relationship stuff
but we are only this is our life this is
our world this is our view of things so
like it's my job to get better it's my
job to be the best version of myself
it's not my job to cast judgment on
other people and as someone who has had
so many traumatic events as a kid and
had to go to court and stuff I do have a
tendency with my PTSD to get hyper
Vigilant that is not my job my job is
not to fight for everyone else my job is
to fight to have the best life right to
shine the most light to be my best
version of myself and if that like rubs
off on other people and they want to do
it too that's what I can and I [ __ ] up
all the time I could be mean and shitty
and and
um you know like self-absorbed or
whatever but it's like I can't like
I had to like unfollow all of the people
that were hypothetically talking about
because I would get triggered like
seeing them and I'm like I don't want to
get this is like I have to like release
myself from the responsibility of this
right right and I do and I hope that
they get better but
like it's not my
yes and I like you know I forgive my my
teacher in the sense that like I release
him from being attached to my life but
I think he's a [ __ ] [ __ ] and I
don't believe he's doing better did you
lose an earring no I think I've always
just had one this whole time
Carlos I'm off in our makeout sash
Carlos Carlos check the tampon pull it
out of the trash suck the tampon make
sure there's not a
suck it out make sure there's not an
earring in there I have to say that
something that changed my opinion on all
this I think maybe for the better was
when recently I've been canceled on
Latin Tick Tock for saying beans are for
ugly people
um I made this Tick Tock video oh my God
you're the Chrissy Teigen of 2022. yeah
I made this video like as I do saying
like what thing like what foods are for
ugly girls because it's just obviously
it's
satire I'm being silly and like I will
never apologize like I but so many
people attacked me for it calling me
racist calling they called me Gru they
called me all these really mean insults
what's grew it's like an ugly character
from Despicable Me yeah I guess I look
like
um you look like Groot is that the name
of the hook yeah grew the tree this is
who they called me
so oh my God that's so cute
but I was just like being attacked on a
massive scale that's so but knowing that
I did nothing wrong and I stand like I'm
not
I'm not standing down like this is in
fact there was a moment where I almost
posted a tick tock that was like I
demand an apology from you for being too
stupid to understand what comedy is but
that's literally my experience on Tech
talk it's just people like not taking
everything you say completely seriously
and being so mad at you I'm like Jesus
Christ and then stitching it with their
own right oh the amount of times I was
stitched and people went off in Spanish
I'm like guys I can't I don't even know
we need to get Ben Affleck to translate
it
but like I just it was so absurd and
there's all of these people though that
really think these horrible things about
me are true and I'm like I'm I'm not
it's not my fight I'm not kidding it's a
fight with them yeah don't get into the
water Jim Fortnight says that don't just
don't get wet with people yeah if
they're getting in the water you don't
have to too bad for us Carlos it's too
hard but then it's like
it's like oh are these people never
gonna forgive me and it's like okay now
I don't like you to begin with they
cried and like I'm mad so imagine this
right just zoom out
everyone is having this really heated
discourse about being yeah like that's
if you zoom out it's comical and
unimportant the conversation is only
because it's like here's a tiny little
Esther saying beans are for ugly girls
and everyone getting their [ __ ]
panties in the bunch over and it's like
that's it's like when you eat a lot of
beans you don't wear your panties in a
bunch okay be careful yeah it was just
there's no there's I have no defense
because I have it's like I would have to
write like a 10 page it's not you know
your intentions you know your intentions
and you don't have to explain yourself
to anyone it's like that's the Trap I
think social media gives you where it's
like you think you just don't just move
forward but that was yeah you're right
that was almost a big lesson for me of
like wait I never have to explain I
never have to apologize if I know how
who I am like I only have to worry about
it's tempting it's tempting I read some
comments I was saying this earlier I
read some comments where this girl's
like and he keeps saying her boyfriend's
age and she's fetishizing him and it's
like if you see my act on the road it's
like my whole point is that like Asian
men have been like desexualized and I'm
trying to like be like date Asian men
they're [ __ ] incredible like I love
my boyfriend he's awesome like like
hello like you know but me even saying
this is me like getting in the water I'm
getting in the water so I'm not in the
water but yeah but also it's like thank
God please fetishize more Asian men
there's they are so [ __ ] hot my
boyfriend's so hot I love so it's like
for the the history of just Asian women
being exoticized I think a [ __ ] word
or it's there is such a you're right I
100 agree with you everyone go [ __ ] and
also his culture like does come into the
conversation like his mother is Asian as
[ __ ] like it I'm having an Asian mom
experience when I'm going to his house
yeah it's not like a regular it's a joy
it's literally I'm not being racist I'm
literally basking in the rice soup of
the life of how to go you're making
observations on your life experience
like I'm half Jewish I talk about Dave
being Jewish I'm like my older Jewish
fiance like does that make me racist
stir fetishize maybe it is but
look pastors fetishized okay I will say
this about beans though okay I will
chime in that I my body has recently
rejected beans
um I love beans so much and it's just
it's a very inflammatory food for me and
I feel like my throat closes up a little
bit
she's what she's trying to say is her
body is hot so basically my body
identifies as a hot girl yeah that's
exactly where I was going with it so
basically does that mean I am gradually
getting hotter
faster I really like you without the eye
makeup honestly you look pretty oh thank
you oh you are fetishizing uh yeah
what's happening
um I would just say that you know look
I've created a little world on Tick Tock
where I decide what things are hot and
what things are ugly and it's just silly
and you know what you did you
entertained all these people who were
bored that are now yelling at you thank
you you gave them something to like feel
about and if you guys are questioning it
I say go watch the video for yourself
and see what you think if you think it's
a serious hate Act of hate or if you
think it's just a girl
like me that is silly
um and while you're there follow me I
have no followers
um I've been trying to not bring this up
because it's actually kind of like
you know how I try not to watch any
Netflix like food document or anything
because I hate like taking on the new
food narratives and stuff I hate like
all of a sudden you watch a thing you're
like I gotta be vegan I gotta do
whatever yes I just randomly went down a
carnivore diet whole okay and I listened
to one hour of a podcast about carnivore
diet and I got convinced that that
plants are poison and they're trying to
kill us and that salads are literally
shaving 30 years off our life and that
we're supposed to be living for 120
years and that we're supposed to just
eat steak like all day and it's the
scariest thing that's ever happened well
Joe Rogan did the carnivore he's on it
now he had well yeah because he's trying
to it's a very quick way obviously to
like lose weight because it's basically
Atkins or keto right but he says that he
had like diarrhea for a whole month yeah
you got like diarrhea from it and then
but you can get scurvy like how are you
I'm surprised you're pooping with it at
all
but it was so convincing like I realized
like in one hour podcast I can be
convinced of anything like it was like
they're like vegetables don't taste good
because they're not supposed to be eaten
like the vegetables are poisoning
because they want to survive they're
like
um you know that's just part of the
vegetable I'm sorry there are a lot of
raw vegetables that are [ __ ]
delicious I mean I'm like seeds yeah
he's scared of salads now what but like
leafy dark leafy greens are supposed to
be like the greatest thing we could ever
enjoy dying at 90 like a like a young
spring little thing I there are some
parts of that that I would have to like
agree with like certain foods are so
like depends on your body certain people
swear by things like broccoli or very
like that [ __ ] [ __ ] me up onions [ __ ]
me up so it's like as much as I like the
taste of it I know my own gut and it it
wreaks Havoc no my body will be very
loud about it
I would say like you have two pieces of
broccoli and you have those like farts
that are sharp you're like oh
they come with Corners like ow
ouch
what
would you even dip a toe in like are you
that far along I no okay wait the day I
listened to that I ended up like eating
like eggs and like ground beef for
breakfast and then by lunch I was like I
want a salad I want a salad it's like my
whole life that convinced me to eat
salad you bait you have to forgo
anything but meat yeah oh no thank you
on that no I just don't like and then
they're like they're saying that like
high cholesterol being bad is a myth I'm
like can you guys do this for like a
hundred years before you bring this to
me I'd like to see someone live to 120.
it's just so scary yeah I know Michaela
Peterson's on it and like the and Jordan
Peterson's on it a lot of the Rogan
people are on it but what they said
started to make sense to me I was like
look I I can see this for like extreme
rapid weight loss because essentially no
this is like a lifestyle this is
supposed to be like forever but
obviously Rogan is not on it until he
has to do like sober October and like do
like the the weight weight loss
competition with birth in them right I
thought somebody said that he he only
eats meat in some fruits and some fruits
and that's all he eats
that's why he's not lean though or
anything like that but something
happened at the UFC fight judging oh
wait Carlos oh I am Carlos versus Rogan
wait wait the food I
Carlos what is your opinion on this meat
diet I think for guys I was just in
Texas and all the guys eat meat like for
two out of three meals if not all three
and all the guys are like way bigger
than me and it's just not the look I
want like I don't think it adds to
health when you're 40. I also want like
girls to like me I don't want to look
like the other guys so yeah like me I'm
not like other guys
I think uh I mean I recently
um started learning about cycling your
workouts according to your natural like
your menstrual cycle and when to do like
hit training according to where you're
at and you're like follicular follicular
face luteal phase and I'm going to start
doing this when you pull the tampon it
flicks onto the ceiling and you go no
it's when you flick kalila's tampons
because think about it dirty bloody puss
it's like even the carnivore diet right
like I wonder how it takes into account
the fact that the period our periods
change like even intermittent fasting
and people are like I swear by it it's
like no the woman's body changes so
drastically day to day you cannot tell
me that one eight eating eight hours
of eight hour window of time when I'm
[ __ ]
you know fully premenstrual is I don't
feel good yeah do you know what also
really scared me that the thing that
scared me the most about it because I
was going on Reddit and like seeing like
what different women said they said that
when you go on the carnivore diet your
lower body fat gets like really like
soft and mushy and I was like I don't
want that that made me feel like
I don't know okay this is weird like
because I too have been learning about
like your cycle and I this is the
analogy that comes up for me so picture
how you know you wake up picture a day
in your life right like you wake up in
the morning you're tired you need to
have your coffee maybe you get a little
morning burst of energy and then you
you're hungry it's lunch time and then
it's afternoon blah blah you go through
the cycle of a day right get tired at
night go to sleep start all over again
that's literally our month our month is
like the first week is like the morning
you know it's just I can't I just it's
so hard for me to process this like we
are literally running on monthly Cycles
I know we've always known that but I
just never realized how different you
feel and how different you are
emotionally physically throughout
different days of the cycle no I don't
know I'm a girl until I'm bleeding on
the couch oh [ __ ] I forgot so much I
mean so much so that men don't even have
to consider that their body temperature
drops at any point in the month like
yeah ours does and the fact that we are
you know like we run hotter certain
times of the month that we're already
burning more doesn't it make your
sleepier if you're hot is that what it
is well I think that like closer like
when you're ovulating you should avoid
like Hot Yoga Extreme like overly like
sweaty things yeah yeah let's like learn
the actual things
um to do hit training and to do more
like so when your
um estrogen is completely down which
means like the week of your period is
when you're most like a man hormonally
so they say that's when it's okay to be
doing more hardcore like you know hit
training like high intensity interval oh
my God that's when you do it and there's
the tampons flies out I will say that I
have a hack for if you want to uh work
out according to your cycle and it's
that only walk yes don't do any other
exercise I will never do hit training
during during any part of my cycle so
I'm safe she's tired of being hit but
you are your favorite guy of all time Dr
David Sinclair says you have to do hit
training once in a while it's hit
training
um occasional fasting
um what is it Sana called plunge and I
don't know what the four things let's
get can we get a um trash Tuesday cold
plunge and sauna please can we get I
don't have a backyard can we get he
would never do our podcast would he no I
shouldn't say that out loud everyone
will do our podcast anybody we want can
we get him yeah that would be amazing
David Sinclair on our podcast yes
Carlos Carlos get on it I have so what
if we did like a monthly like medical
one we could have like the egg doctor on
one episode you know well I am more
desperate than anything in life to have
Dr Drew back on this show I know oh my
God that was the most soothing day of my
life I had a dream that Dr Drew was like
wanted to like hang out and like chat
and I was like so excited and things
kept happening like
I kept going to like the wrong
restaurant or like there weren't enough
tables or something and I was like ah I
was like so desperate for Dr Drew any
I'm concerned about your dreams lately
it's like it seems that you're always in
the place you want to be you're finally
getting to the places you have to be but
you're I can't really you can't reach it
oh how about okay so I I told you I
relapsed on on um True Crime I started
watching frogging a new thing that I now
need to worry about where people hide in
your attic and live in your house and
frog you so that I had a Frogger dream
where this old assistant that I had I
feel like this is a career path for you
I was just thinking like wait who has an
attic it's so it's so scary it's the
scariest thing in the world and so like
I had a dream where this girl was like
frogging in my house and it was so scary
and then I was trying to get tied up I
was like to tell him and my voice
wouldn't work what does the frog do like
what is the point one guy okay so
there's this whole series I saw I don't
know if it's like on life it's on one of
the true colors okay and it's like one
of the episodes was this guy was like
stalking this family and he had all
these plans of he was gonna like chop
them up and turn them into like half
lizard people or something titles yes
it's way scarier than someone just I
thought maybe it was just a hobby of
like being in a place you're not
supposed to and some guy was like was
like a cross-dresser was like dressing
in these girls clothes and you know what
it is this is why you can't believe in
ghosts okay all these a lot of the
people were like it must be ghosts it's
like no there's another living in your
goddamn house okay that is [ __ ] ghost
Stop Believing in ghosts okay let it
become a ghost after the cops have come
and caught the Frog okay
that is such a good time because listen
I've kissed some frogs I do not want to
get chopped up by a frog and turned into
a serpent person I told you I dated a
boy named froggy
he wasn't very cute but he was very fast
he was a very fast swimmer so that's big
bonus points in my book anyway shout out
the New York Post I still love you what
there was some frogging not too long ago
what couple had this guy in his house
and they said he wanted to play doctor
on them I think that's the that might be
the one I saw Esther of all your um
famous hot friends whose house would you
frog
well Whitney's would be the easiest
Whitney how long before she catches I
could live in Winnie's house the rest of
my life and she would never know I
convinced
I could live there but one of her dogs
would find you
they would just bite her again it
wouldn't live by Whitney Whitney would
be in the hospital again getting yeah
handling a bite I think me and Annie
could live on Whitney's house and
grounds forever and no one would ever
know her chicken Whitney got me into
chicken chips they're chips that are
made of chicken
they're so good is it not like
chicharron no they're literally like
they're like potato they're they're like
I guess a you know yeah those ones wow
there's a chicken and waffle one that's
pretty damn good oh my God she's even
waffle it's so good but realistically I
think
I would like to frog in my parents attic
or crawl space I think that's what's
next but then you would have to take
care of yourself that's the problem
oh because they wouldn't know I'm there
how what do they subsist on while
they're frogging up their Annie like
what are they have they already brought
their uh well when you leave the
provisions no that's just like I think
they eat yours no I think I figured it
out I live in the Attic right and then
at night my parents go to sleep and then
I come out I watch TV I have a snack and
then I can just leave my my mess out go
back in my attic and then my mom wakes
up in the morning she'll put she'll
clean up my mess and
she'll just do it without it's such a
habit to her she won't even think about
where the mess came make it look like
the dog did it yeah
I'll [ __ ] on the floor
so they think pepper had a crazy night
you guys another chaotic day in our
lives that's right baby
um you guys thank you so much for
returning again and again to the three
old sperms that would be nothing without
you we will see you guys next
[ __ ] Tuesday
foreign
[Music]
[Music]